Superman is indisputably the most
powerful superhero in the world he's
indestructible and wields the most
comprehensive array of super powers
imaginable from super hearing all the
way to super ventriloquism and he does
it all with a friendly smirk just this
side of smug but considering how tough
Superman is there's still a surprisingly
long list of characters who have
actually defeated him heroes and
villains alike how here's a look at just
a few of the characters who have knocked
the curl right off his forehead Batman
on paper
Batman beating Superman seems impossible
unless that paper is between the covers
of a comic book in that case well you
could pretty much write Superman's
epitaph because Batman has time and
again shown that he has what it takes to
put Superman 6 feet under
usually of course the world's greatest
detective wins thanks to the world's
greatest cheat code otherwise known as
kryptonite which ironically Superman
himself gave Batman as a fail-safe just
in case Superman went rogue in The Dark
Knight Returns comic book Batman also
had a couple other tricks up his sleeve
namely Green Arrow and a soviet union
that like to drop nukes that really
isn't playing fair is it
doomsday spoiler alert but in Batman vs
Superman not only does that man beat
Superman using kryptonite Superman also
gets killed by doomsday just like what
happens when the two fought in the
comics doomsday doesn't have any tricks
or anything
he's a one-note villain whose only
purpose in the comics is to kill
Superman using brute force in the
infamous death of Superman's storyline
doomsday did just that as part of a
spectacular double ko as villains go
doomsday is pretty boring but he got the
job done the Avengers that you weren't
expecting to see the Avengers on this
list with them being from a completely
different publisher at all but Marvel's
Mightiest Heroes did indeed put the
ultimate smackdown on Superman in the
pages of Avengers JLA number two in this
hotly contested inter universe crossover
Superman and Thor went toe-to-toe
Superman barely beat Thor but ended the
fight dazed and severely weakened
was more than enough of an opening for
Thor's Avenger buddies to do what they
do best avenge him the team's heaviest
hitters Ironman Hercules Wonder Man
division and she-hulk dog piled on
Superman and pummeled him unconscious
Lex Luthor Superman's archenemy Lex
Luthor has defeated Superman so many
times it's kind of hard to just pick one
example our favorite instance of Lex
dropping the hammer on Superman comes
from the classic Superman number 149
where Lex wins Superman's trust by
curing cancer with Superman convinced
that Lex has reformed it's easy for
Luthor to trick Superman into a fatal
kryptonite trap
Supergirl later brought Lex to justice
for Superman's murder it's a sad story
but on the other hand Lex cured cancer
sorry Supes but that's not really a bad
trade-off in our book Mongol
Superman's most dangerous foe may be
Mongol who's basically what you would
get if you combine Doomsday's incredible
strength with Lex Luthor's genius Mongol
has repeatedly gotten the better of
Superman beating him both physically and
psychologically case in point the
classic Superman annual number 11 by
Watchmen writer Alan Moore in which
Mongol trapped Superman inside his own
dreams
luckily for Superman and earth at large
Robin defeats Mongol yes Robin we're not
sure who should be more embarrassed
Superman or Mongol Captain Marvel
Superman pretty much has only two major
weaknesses kryptonite and magic
unfortunately for him there's Captain
Marvel
who's alternately known as Shazam
depending on whether DC Comics wants to
publish stories about a dude with the
word Marvel in his name that day he's
not only just as powerful as Superman
but he got those powers from a super
wizard meaning he's powered by magic
that gives Captain Marvel a pretty
significant leg up on Superman the two
have fought numerous times usually
Superman often wins in the end because
Captain Marvel is actually a little kid
in an adult body
but the big red cheese has knocked soups
out more than once and has even taken
Superman out with some well-timed bolts
of magic lightning Atlas speaking of
people with magic on their side
there's Atlas that's right this dumb
looking dork is actually the same guy
who carried the world on his shoulders
in Greek mythology well in the comics
he's well there's no way to explain it
that makes any sense so just trust us
when we say that he's a really strong
dude and in Superman number 677 to
number 680 Atlas absolutely pounded the
tar out of Superman and he did the same
to everyone who tried to stop him
luckily for Superman he had an ally much
much tougher than even the Man of Steel
Krypto the Superdog where Superman
failed miserably Krypto succeeded taking
Atlas down and saving metropolis and the
world good doggie Green Lantern remember
how Superman is vulnerable to kryptonite
well usually that's not such a big deal
thanks to the fact that there's not all
that much of it around however way back
in DC Comics presents number 26
a villain posing as Hal Jordan the Green
Lantern of Earth discovered a loophole
the Green Lantern ring can actually
create a form of synthetic kryptonite
once the real Green Lantern knocked the
bad guy out the fake kryptonite
disappeared and eventually the power of
kryptonite creation was removed by comic
book writers on account of it being well
ridiculous but Green Lantern eventually
found another way to take Superman out
he bonded with the alien entity named
parallax and became an omnipotent evil
god hey if you can't beat them join them
the Joker
even though the Joker has yet to figure
out a way to defeat a rich playboy in a
bat mask he's somehow defeated Superman
multiple times for instance in Emperor
Joker the Joker stole the powers of mr.
mixon um mr. mixon mix old mr. Mixel
flick
no repeated to me
bright boy it's yeah that guy the Joker
stole his powers and reshaped reality
that included sealing Superman away in
Arkham Asylum shoes on the other foot
now meanwhile in the injustice gods
among us video game The Joker tricked
Superman into murdering Lois Lane then
the Joker nukes Metropolis
you know what that's not actually funny
effective but not funny
yuk Mohammed Ali finally we come to the
greatest for many people Muhammad Ali
was as close to a real-life superhero as
will ever get so it doesn't come as a
huge surprise to learn that he once laid
out Superman the fight took place in the
aptly titled
Superman versus Muhammad Ali an alien
army attacks earth and proposes a simple
contest of Champions to determine the
fate of the world to decide who should
be Earth's representative ali and
superman have a boxing match
with superman fighting without his
superpowers so it was essentially Ali
versus nerdy weakling Clark Kent so what
happened Ali not Superman senseless in
the end Ali also defeated the alien
champion in single combat saving the
planet and all this fresh off his battle
against mr. tooth decay thanks for
watching subscribe to our YouTube
channel to watch more videos like the
one you just saw and leave us a comment
to let us know how you would kick
Superman's butt